Gary court order for asset seizures so
they're taking my car you and radio
silent on me is that what this is about
just last night and I thought I missed
that is that true bonjourno that's my
cousin Gary I swear to God he's my
cousin
he's my second cousin there's something
seriously wrong with you
I'm an Uber driver and I don't have a
car I'm gonna lose my house you think I
chose
[Music]
look at this need a car date our son
this summer and bring him out of his
shell before College in exchange will
give you a Buick Regal date is in quotes
it's got to be a joke right no have you
seen these helicopter parents I'm
surprised they're not gonna themselves
you've just been so worried about our
son he's going to Princeton in the fall
no I've heard of it you know we tried
everything to bring him out of his shell
he doesn't come out of his room he
doesn't talk to girls and drinks so when
you say date him do you mean date him or
date him yes date him date him hard I'll
date his brains out he volunteers at the
animal shelter
hi mind if I touch your wiener what your
dog
how about I give you a ride home
um this is in the way to my house it's a
shortcut
you're my hostage what you got down
there something for me
Ian grow up
have a drink together he'll have a Long
Island Iced Tea
[Music]
this is the worst iced tea I've ever had
one thing about me I'm the baddest alive
dance party I don't know what to do I
just know my mom would have wanted me to
save the house I was probably just
nervous
can't you loosen them up we can go
skinny dipping what about sharks many
it's really the lack of lifeguard here
right now okay
I'm just a bit of a romantic he's
actually really sweet the best part
about getting older is not giving up
people think I'm an adult now I can make
my own decisions that's that's good you
want to save it
come on you're getting out of here you
don't belong here touch me get away from
her stay
I can't lose my license
[Music]
foreign